[Music]
welcome back so this is one of my
favorite lectures on the singular value
decomposition and eigenfaces and this is
an example I show in my class at u-dub a
lot and I haven't uploaded this dataset
for copyright reasons but I wanted to
show you here kind of walk you through
this example so here what we're gonna do
is we're gonna find the eigen faces of a
bunch of faces and we're gonna use those
to cluster two different people in I can
face space but in particular we're gonna
load and cluster action-hero Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Sylvester Stallone
okay so this is like an eigen heroes
example and I'm just gonna walk you
through this the code is pretty simple
it's very similar to the other eigen
face example and what I'm gonna first do
is I've taken all of these images of
these two action heroes online and I've
cropped and roughly aligned them while I
was watching Terminator I cropped and
aligned these images so that their faces
were more or less in the same place and
filling the same box and each image is a
200 by 175 image I have 20 pictures of
Arnold 20 pictures of Stallone and I'm
gonna put them all into this big a
matrix so the first 20 columns are gonna
be Arnold the second 20 columns are
gonna be Stallone okay
and so here we're gonna just load them
up so you're gonna load all of these I
have a folder called faces and it's got
Arnold oh one Arnold oh two and so on
Stallone oh one Stallone oh two and so
on so I'm going to load them I'm gonna
check to see if they're already
greyscale or if they're color I'm gonna
convert them to greyscale I'm gonna plot
them to the screen and I'm gonna pause
for a tenth of a second so you can see
the image and as I'm going through this
I'm going to keep track I'm gonna add
that image to the average so that I can
build up this average as I load the
images now notice here I have this 256 -
you in my image show that's only because
I've done a hard invert of my color on
my laptop so it has a black background
you would just do image show of you to
make it look normal okay
okay so let's load Arnold oh alright
let's try to load all of these and now
load Arnold okay so we have the these
pictures of Arnold these are 20 images I
pulled from the Internet's okay and now
what we're going to do is similarly
we're going to load Stallone 20 images
of him from the net same exact code okay
good so now we have a count of 40
because we have 20 images of Arnold 20
images of Stallone and at the end of
this I took my average face I added up
all of those faces and I divided by 40
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to compute the average action-hero
so this is the average face I'm just
going to plot it that's what it looks
like pretty nondescript kind of a buzz
cut good jawline right it's just an
average action-hero and now what we're
gonna do is we're going to take all of
those 40 images and we're gonna subtract
off that average face and create this
this matrix B okay so we're essentially
doing principal component analysis
actually we're finding the principal
components of an action hero so I'm
going to subtract that off of every
column of my a matrix that's super fast
and here's where all the magic happens
now I'm gonna plot my s I'm going to
compute my SVD so I'm gonna do an
economy SVD of this Big B matrix and I
should probably show you what the size
of B is okay so the size of B is
thirty-five thousand by 14 so for each
of my action heroes I have a thirty five
thousand pixel image that I've reshaped
into a tall skinny column vector so I
took the image and I reshaped it in into
a tall skinny vector using the reshape
command and then I have 20 of Arnold and
20 of Stallone so 40 total we're gonna
compute the SVD and the columns of u are
going to be my eigen heroes okay and for
some reason I'm rewriting the U matrix
into something called fee in
six often time our our modes are called
fee and so I called it fee here but that
doesn't really matter and then I'm going
to create a nine by nine plot plotting
my first nine eigen heroes here okay and
they will be linear combinations of the
images I fed in they have to be that's
how this works okay
so these are my nine Augen action heroes
the eigen phases of the library
containing Arnold and Stallone and so
you can actually start to see right this
is the the first most dominant mode the
second the third and so on and so forth
and you can see some pretty interesting
features in this right off the bat first
of all this one looks kind of like the
average face right it's kind of just
some hair and a face but then you can
start to actually see some real features
in the in the lower energy eigen faces
so like you see Terminator glasses clear
as day here in fact you can actually see
Terminator glasses and a lot of these
images apparently that's a very dominant
feature over here I don't know if you
can see it but that certainly looks like
Stallone's eye and so you can get this
idea that these eigenfaces really are a
linear combination of the the training
data these are my eigen action heroes
and now what's super interesting is I
can take each image each of my tall
reshaped vectors my images and I can
project them into those principal
components into the principal component
one two and three my first three most
dominant eigen heroes I can take every
picture of my for my library and I can
project it into that space so I can go
from a 35,000 dimensional vector to a
three dimensional vector of how much
that image contained of principal face
one two and three what's the linear
combination of those eigenfaces to give
image one image two and so on and so
it's really easy to do I literally just
take my image vector times my library
it's all transposed here but this is
just my image vector
my image vector projected into the first
three eigenfaces I can face space for
Arnold and first alone so these are
their three coordinates in the first
three principal components and then I'm
just gonna plot them as different
colored markers okay
and put a legend of Arnold versus
Stallone so here what I've done is I've
projected both of these guys into their
two into three principal components and
so Arnold are the blue dots and Stallone
are the yellow dots and you can actually
see you get pretty good separation they
do look different and so it's not
surprising that when you plot these in
their in their feature space you get
these kind of different clouds of Arnold
and Stallone now I will point out that
the separation is not perfect there is
some overlap in these distributions and
that kind of makes sense that they're
not perfectly separated but there is you
know some plane I could find where they
separate better and where most of the
Arnold points and most of the Stallone
points are kind of separate from each
other but what I think is kind of neat
here is that you can then take a test
image that was not in your training data
set and you can project it into eigen
face coordinates and you can see does
that new test image live closer to the
Arnold cluster or to the Stallone
cluster and that's the basic idea behind
image classification is that you have
this kind of cluster of Arnold points
and a cluster of Stallone points and if
I have a new image and I projected in if
it's closer to the Arnold cluster it's
probably Arnold so here we're gonna do
this with kind of a cute example where
now our two test images I hope you can
see this there is it's a little bit dark
but I hope you can see it so this is
Harry Potter Stallone okay so someone
photoshopped this and this is the TV
Terminator Summer Glau so it's not
exactly Stallone and it's not exactly
Arnold but it is you know mostly
Stallone and at least here we have a
terminator eye so it's maybe it is like
the Terminator
and what we're gonna do is we're going
to take these two vectors and we're
gonna project them into our three our
first three eigen coordinates our eigen
face coordinates and see where they live
and so when we do this it's maybe a
little bit hard to see but I think you
can you can in fact see this the white
point right here that was the TV
Terminator and she drops very solidly in
the Arnold camp so it apparently just
from that one image she projects very
much into the Terminator a group of
faces so you would classify her as our
Noldor as a terminator and the harry
potter stallone this pink dot up here
projects also pretty nicely into the
yellow stallone cluster of images so
even though these images weren't perfect
they do actually project very nicely
into the right correct classification
category okay so this is just kind of a
cute example of how this classification
could work and how images work in
general or image compression using the
SVD works in general now I think one
thing that's also fun is if I take
Arnold
I keep Arnold Arnold actually let's
change Arnold to Taylor Swift okay we're
gonna do exactly the same thing but now
we're gonna do Taylor Swift versus
Stallone let me change the name down
here so instead of Arnold it's Taylor
Swift okay so we're gonna do the same
exact thing and we're gonna see how
these images clusters these are 20
images of Taylor Swift okay 20 images
same 20 images of Stallone and we're
going to do a hypothesis we're gonna I
always ask my students in class like do
you think do you think Arnold and
Stallone are going to be more separated
or Taylor Swift and Stallone are gonna
be more separated or her and and Arnold
okay now the average face here again is
a pretty blobby face but it definitely
has kind of more you can see more of the
Taylor Swift in in this face longer hair
certainly we're gonna subtract off the
mean from all of the faces again we're
gonna compute the SVD and the first nine
eigenfaces I think these are super
interesting looking I mean very
different than before so I mean these
kind of 1st and 3rd are these very kind
of pixie looking I can face is very
different than the arnold stallone
eigenfaces you can still see some
Stallone in here and now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna project each
image again into the first three eigen
faces and now instead of Arnold we're
gonna have Taylor dots and Stallone dots
so she is blue and he is yellow and what
you see is actually really I would say
quite good separation this is actually
better separation than Stallone and
Arnold I think I think this is this is
really good separation that's kind of
what you might expect
maybe her face is more different than
still her and Stallone's face are more
different than Arnold and Stallone okay
so you get better separation but let's
do one more test and instead of doing
Taylor and Stallone let's do Taylor and
Arnold okay so I'm gonna keep this one
Taylor now I'm gonna load Arnold for the
second image and we're gonna do this
this is the last test we're gonna try so
again we're gonna load 20 Taylor I'm not
changing these little comment titles
because that's gonna take too much time
so 20 Taylor we're gonna load 20 Arnold
okay good
we're gonna do all the same stuff we're
gonna compute the average face again
kind of a gray looking face we're gonna
subtract that off so that we're really
doing principal components and compute
the SVD and I'm gonna make that much
much bigger
so these eigen faces again you can
definitely see some Taylor here and some
Terminator over here and now I'm gonna
project Taylor and Arnold in and again I
want you to do this thought experiment
do you think that they're gonna be
farther apart than Arnold and Stallone
or closer together I'll let you decide
okay interesting so here this is where
my class usually is kind of blown away
you actually see that these are pretty
overlapping distributions they're
actually way more overlapping than
Arnold and Stallone or Taylor and
Stallone so apparently Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Taylor Swift are more
alike in eigen face space for at least
these first three eigen spigen
coordinates then Arnold in Stallone or
Taylor in Stallone and I always ask why
this might be and I think the answer you
know I can't tell you the exact answer
but I think the answer is actually
pretty simple and maybe a little shallow
and it kind of points to some of the
issues with these naive image
classification techniques just based on
correlations and the data Taylor Swift
and Arnold Schwarzenegger are both
fair-skinned blonde hair right like they
both have just lighter pixels on average
okay so if you're gonna dot-product
their faces on average you're gonna get
more correlation even if one one's a guy
and one's a girl okay so this always
kind of confuses my class or maybe you
know people think that that the the guys
and the girls are gonna have the biggest
separation because for us as humans we
have you know that kind of that prior or
that bias that those are more different
but according to the eigenfaces you know
skin tone and hair color
sure carries a lot of the information
that you would use for that inner
product
okay so you can kind of see some of the
shallowness of image classification in
this in this little toy example but I
think it's really fun to work this out
and just to see what what happens
something else that's kind of
interesting so Facebook before you know
moving to deep neural network
architectures when they were using more
simple algorithms for face
classification for telling to who's who
in a picture for a long time they were a
few percentage point below human
accuracy in telling people apart in
pictures and at some point they finally
broke even with humans or maybe even do
a little bit better
and the technology that went into this
is super interesting so everything I've
shown you here are two-dimensional
images these kind of 2d representations
of faces but you know that a face is not
two-dimensional it is a representation
of a three-dimensional face on a
three-dimensional skull and so what
Facebook did was they started to realize
that you could take those images and you
could infer what the three-dimensional
geometry of the actual human head would
have been so you know based on shadows
you can get the depth of nose and
eyebrows and things like that and when
you take those images and map them to to
a skeleton you can get that last little
bit of performance that humans have
because of course that's also what we're
doing we have stereo vision and we know
that we live in a three-dimensional
world okay so this is one of my favorite
examples kind of the eigen action heroes
and and eigenfaces you can load your own
images and play around with us too okay
thank you